ladies this club has a reputation bottle
service rate roses can make between
1,000 and 3,000 a ninth but you got to
work hard
discretion is valued above all else in
these circles
we regret to inform you that your
daughter Rachel was found dead Rachel I
didn't kill herself she was working in
some sleazy nightclub she felt her
Branka hey Soph it's a journal I am sure
that he knows what really happened to
Rachel what are things we're looking for
isn't club Zoe everyone at that club is
crazy
Rachel deserves the truth have you ever
worked in a club zone tired as a
waitress
let's try it out hi what can we get you
think we'll have a bucket one bottle sir
worth thousand dollars what if I told
you there was a way you can make even
more very important thing was having a
party his house tonight he's gonna be
really pleased to see so glad you came
there's something you should know about
your sister
we thought you were dead you some kind
of private eye not some kind of he was
working for me what's the plan we need
to take them down I have to break in
there I'm going with you
you're direct
you